so because the video on apocalypse
versus Thanos was so well-received by
everyone I figured we try another video
this time focusing on spider-man and
Batman and so because the basis of this
idea is to take two characters who have
never met and pit them against one
another we're gonna follow the same
formula focusing on various aspects of
these characters asking at the end of
the video who would come out on top
so starting with spider-man his physical
strength is pretty straightforward here
and that he possesses the standard run
of abilities including the strength to
lift cars with little effort and easily
Bend almost all medals with the
exception of vibranium and adamantium
something to also note is that among
most readers it's largely agreed upon
that whenever he engages in fights
spider-man likely pulls his punches
against all but the most powerful
enemies that he faces due to the fact
that he would likely kill some of the
physically weaker enemies like Mysterio
or Doctor Octopus furthermore
spider-man's body is far tougher than a
normal person able to withstand Falls
and impacts that would disable or kill a
common person and his metabolism has
also greatly increased allowing for a
higher tolerance of drugs and
accelerated healing and focusing on his
agility spider-man possesses far
superior agility that even a
super-powered human like Captain America
and he's been able to dodge gunfire at
point-blank range as a result the
enemies he faces have a very difficult
time hitting him as he uses not only his
superior speed and agility to his
advantage but also uses his web slinging
abilities and his extraordinary sense of
balance allowing him to fight and
unusual angles focusing on his
intelligence and probably the most
important part of his character
emulation of Batman while he's not as
smart as Reed Richards dr. doom or
Amadeus Cho spider-man is a genius-level
intellect being one of the tops in his
field regarding chemistry biology
physics and engineering in addition to
this he's also an inventor of great
skill developing the web shooters that
he's well known for and showing an
ability to uses and mending skills to
overcome enemies when his physical
prowess can't do the job regarding his
fighting powers spider-man has an
ability to sense danger and combined
with his enhanced agility strength and
durability makes him a powerful and
dangerous foe however despite these
abilities when going against someone
like Captain America
Peter was shown to be completely
outmatched although it is believed this
is do more to Captain America's vast
experience fighting in World War 2
along with fighting alongside the
Avengers after his revival however one
of the most powerful tools is his joking
manner which is explained explicitly be
due to his desire to throw his enemies
off-kilter but also keep his mind
focused during the heat of combat
now the weaknesses of spider-man can be
counted on one hand but the significance
of these weaknesses in question can
be overlooked despite being incredibly
durable he's not immune to conventional
weapons in addition to this his
accelerated healing factor is not on par
with Wolverines meaning that he could be
damaged can succumb to illnesses and
he's not immortal furthermore villains
like venom have the ability to avoid his
spiders since making this weakness
almost crippling and that Spider Man has
to rely almost strictly on his wits and
experience to overcome these foes the
net transitioning to Batman where he
doesn't have super-strength like
spider-man
he has conditioned himself to the peak
of human ability in addition to this his
drive and will to succeed makes him
highly resistant to pain and my control
attempts and his martial arts and
training has allowed him to roll with
hits that would kill normal human beings
however his lack of strength and
durability is offset by the fact that he
uses a bat suit which has been shown to
deflect small caliber gunfire and some
flame based attacks on the other hand
Batman also has peak level human agility
and is a master of stealth disguise and
escapology
meaning he could escape virtually any
restraint and uses shadows for deception
in addition to occasionally using
flashbangs to effectively confuse and
disorient his enemies now focusing on
his intellect Batman has one of the
sharpest minds in the DC Universe and is
a highly skilled scientist and inventor
his extravagant wealth allows him access
to cutting-edge technology and his
creativity allows him to be prepared for
almost any situation that he may find
himself in something to also note here
is that he carries a utility belt that
nearly always has what he needs to
accomplish any task and his strategies
have allowed him to stay one step ahead
of nearly every enemy now for his
fighting prowess
Batman is absolutely formidable and that
he's a master of nearly every martial
art on earth and is one of the best
hand-to-hand fighters in the comic book
universe furthermore Batman has aided in
his hand-to-hand prowess by access to
enhancements through various gadgets if
he needs it and at times has used his
gauntlets to shock his enemies or in the
case of the Dark Knight Returns a
powered suit to enhance the strength to
superhuman levels now looking at his
experience
Batman is one of the most experienced
chemical characters ever fighting not
only every type of enemy imaginable on
this planet but sometimes others as well
his ability to use his mind and also
exploit an enemy's weak
is legendary and he's been able to
defeat enemies much more powerful than
himself
however much like spider-man Batman is
not without his weaknesses even though
he has trained himself to peak human
levels at the end of the day he's still
human meaning that any attack that can
pierce his armor can hurt him
incapacitate him or possibly even kill
him as was the case during nightfall
when his back was broken by Bane and so
having said that which of these
characters would come out on top in
truth the answer to this question comes
down to a number of factors would this
fight take place on common ground would
it be spontaneous or where they have
time to plan or strategize would Batman
be allowed to use his utility belt from
a purely physical standpoint the
advantage would have to go to spider-man
with his enhanced strength durability
and athletic prowess however because of
his intelligence
Batman would likely find a way to take
advantage of spider-man's
vulnerabilities and cancel out his
spidey sense or even change the
environment such as forcing them to
fight in water which would neutralize
spider-man's agility and speed advantage
and so ultimately I actually have to
side with Batman in this one due to the
fact that despite his vulnerabilities in
the end he's simply too smart and too
experienced to be taken down by Peter
Parker
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end and let me know
down in the comments section who do you
think would win this fight Batman or
spider-man and I will catch you guys on
peace